Does mental illness and gun violence actually
have a scientific connection?
After every major mass shooting in the U.S.,
there is always a discussion about whether
or not the perpetrator's mental health was
to blame.
A recent study even showed that news media
pairs mental illness with violence at a higher
rate than it actually occurs.
Oh, and then, there’s this guy.
And yea, the shooter he’s talking about
did have a history of mental illness, but
there is still a lack of scientific evidence
to support the idea that America’s gun problem
is rooted in mental health.
In fact, there is actually data that shows
the opposite is true.
Several epidemiological studies have shown
that there is little to no correlation between
mental illness and violence towards others.
This includes people who suffer from schizophrenia,
bipolar disorder, and severe depression.
The National Institute of Mental Health carried
out one of the first studies on the subject
in 1990.
They collected data from over 10,000 people
across three major U.S. cities.
The study accounted for things like socioeconomic
status and substance abuse problems.
The ultimate conclusion was that if we were
to somehow eliminate the risk of people with
mental illnesses carrying out violent crimes,
the amount of violent crimes in the U.S. would
only drop by 4%.
A few years later, the MacArthur Violence
Risk Assessment Study followed more than 1,000
psychiatric patients who had been discharged
from medical care.
The study discovered that patients who suffered
only from a serious mental illness and had
no substance abuse problems had the same risk
in committing violent behavior as anyone else
in their communities.
And according to more recent national data
from the U.S. Department of Health and Human
Services, only 3-5% of violent acts can be
attributed to people who have serious mental
illnesses.
Now, the rate of violent crimes for this population
does goes up when you mix in substance abuse,
but that’s true for the general population
as well.
On the flip side of this, people who suffer
from serious mental illnesses are 10 times
more likely to be the victims of violent crimes
than members of the general population.
They are also often the victims of self-inflicted
violence.
Over half of gun fatalities in the U.S. are
from suicide.
Experts believe that an emphasis on suicide
would be a better policy approach in preventing
gun violence, for which there is plenty of
evidence and data, as opposed to focusing
on mental illness’ connection to mass murders,
for which there is little data.
Lastly, finding a scientific connection between
gun violence and anything can be difficult
nowadays.
That’s because there was legislation passed
in the late 1990s that essentially pulls funding
away from any federal agency looking to study
gun violence as a public health issue.
I mean, the CDC gets funding to study rare
diseases like cholera, diphtheria, polio,
and rabies.
Over the last 40 years those diseases have
only killed around 2,000 people in the U.S.
In that same time frame, 1.4 million Americans
have died because of firearms.
So let’s remember that, even when we see
headlines like this.
And have a president who says things like
this.
So, if science can’t solve the gun problem,
what can it do?
Lots.
Like, how about cleaning the air with bicycles?
Find out about it here.
Don’t forget to subscribe, and be sure to
come back to seeker for more videos.